[Music]
one of the key themes of a wizard of
earthsea that comes up in the very first
chapter and then runs throughout the
work and will show up in the other earth
sea
novels and short stories as well is that
power is not all that it's cracked up to
be or
anticipated or
desired including by some of the
characters ged himself who's you know it
rather impatient to start learning how
to
use the power and potential that he has
to have even more power to do things to
gain
honor reputation
power over things knowledge right and he
encounters others as well
and
what's wrong with power well
when you
have some of it
you enter into a world
that
is sort of like a vast game or
marketplace or pool or arena whatever
metaphor you want
and you having a bit of power
particularly if you've got great
potential as ged does
makes you a target
for others in a variety
of different ways it could be the scorn
that jasper
pours upon him jasper is
another student at roque who's from a
much more you know well-titled
background than this gandish uh goat
herder
type right
who who's dead even though ged has much
greater power and potential in terms of
magic jasper is ahead of him and can
give him a hard time or it can be much
less we could say innocuous i shouldn't
say completely innocuous because
jasper's goading leads get into doing
something that disrupts the very
equilibrium
but it can be
dangers of others
wanting to use your power wanting to
seduce you to control you
to harness to
use your power as something to augment
their own power to make you powerless
except in so far as you use your power
their way there's also important
temptations
that come with having power and a lot of
this is illustrated in one of the
very first relationships and exchanges
that we see in the very first chapter
ged's aunt his sister's mother takes an
interest in him because
she realizes that this kid
can do
magic like she can
so she tells him
i will bind your promise
your tongue will be stilled into a until
i choose to unbind it even then though
you can speak your you will not be able
to speak the word i teach you where
another person can hear it we must keep
the secrets of our craft good said the
boy for he had no wish to tell the
secret to his playmates liking to know
and do what they knew not and could not
he sat still while his aunt bound back
her uncombed hair
she began to sing her voice changed and
she speaks to him
the the spell and then says speak to
test the spell the boy could not speak
but he laughed
then his aunt was a little afraid of his
strength for this was the strongest
spell as she knew how to weave now
notice what it says here
she had tried not only to gain control
of his speech and silence but
to bind him at the same time to her
service in the craft of sorcery yet as
the spell bound him he had laughed
she said nothing and what's what's going
on there
she wants to control him she wants to
use the power that she sees she's not
being
completely up front with him
she's not treating him as a nephew she's
treating him as
a tool and she's just not strong enough
to pull it off
and as we see here
she goes on
to earn the words of power he did all
the which asked of him and he learned
all she taught though not all of it was
pleasant to do or no the witch of ten
elders was no black sorceress but being
an ignorant woman
among ignorant folks she often used her
crafts to foolish and dubious ends she
knew nothing of the balance and the
pattern which the true wizard knows and
serves which keep him from using his
spells unless real need demands this
thing that will be called the
equilibrium in other
chapters within
this work so on the one hand
she is trying to
use ged at that time called dunny
doesn't even have the name get yet
on the other hand she is also somebody
who's given into
temptations and ignorance on her own
part in her use of magic
so there's this really interesting
paradox going on here
power
you would think
would be something that
makes our life better having more power
makes us
able to be strong and free to get what
we want but what happens
when we have some power when we have
talent when we have capacity we get on
the radar
of other people who have been around
longer than us and have more advantages
and want to use us for their
own ends others want to
take control of us and use us and ogen
the mage who
names ged and takes him on as an
apprentice explains this after ged
screws up after the
first attempt
to seduce him
into becoming somebody else's thrall and
we should actually talk about this a
little bit
there's a a girl that he begins talking
to
in ray albee
the daughter of the old lord of rey alby
and she says i wish you would tell me
about sorcery and ged wants to please
her to win her admiration and he allows
her to
talk him into or goad him into
finding a spell in one of ogean's books
she does so by saying can you change
your own shape as wizards do and he says
i might if i choose and eventually she
says are you afraid to
no i'm not afraid maybe you're too young
then and so he decides he's going to do
it and he goes looking through the spell
books
and things go wrong
and it turns out as odinn says
you don't remember that that girl's
mother the lord's wife is an enchantress
indeed ojun had once said this ged had
not paid much attention though he knew
now that ojin never told him anything he
had not good reason to tell him the girl
herself is a half a witch already and
maybe the mother who sent the girl to
talk to you it may be she who opened the
book to the page you read the powers she
serves are not the powers i serve i do
not know her will but i know she does
not will me well
ged listen to me
have you never thought how danger
must surround power
as shadow does light
so the idea there is that not
everybody's going to be
nice and helpful they're not going to
say oh fellow magic user wow we're all
in the same thing no they will try to
control you they will try to
use you
the shadow
that ged brings into the world we find
out also wants to use him as well
and we're told how this will happen
when the arc mage is talking to get
after the shadow has been released
the arc mage says
you have great power in born in you you
use that power wrongly you summoned a
spirit but with it came one of the
powers of unlife uncalled it came from a
place where there are no names evil
it wills to work evil through you
you are connected with it and if it does
take control over you
then this is going to be particularly
bad because
you have power that it can use you have
capacities
later on he talks about the danger
that will happen this is where gatt is
talking with ogian after
uh coming back to to gantt
and he says um
[Music]
if it defeats me
then it will take my knowledge and my
power
and use them it threatens only me now
but if it enters into me and possesses
me it will work great evil through me it
wants to turn ged
into a thing called a gebbeth which is
sort of a hollowed-out shell
of a person whose
will and personality has been effaced by
the evil that now
inhabits the person and uses it like a
puppet or like an article of clothing a
wizard gebbeth would be very dangerous
indeed
there's another very interesting
section that takes place having to do
with one of the old powers
up in oskill one of the northern
islands
with the stone of the taranon and this
involves
the now grown up
young girl who ged had run into
before
so there's this long discussion between
them
uh her name is sarah
and she says
have you heard of this this stone it's a
famous thing
the jewel outshines all the famous
treasuries would you like to see it she
smiled with the look of mockery and
daring as if a little afraid of what she
did she led the young man from the hall
down to the base of the tower downstairs
underground to a locked door he had not
seen before
she showed a small room like a dungeon
cell floor walls ceiling all rough stone
unfurnished blank do you see it
as ged looked around the room his
wizard's eye caught one stone of those
that made the floor it was rough and
dank as the rest a heavy unshapen paving
stone yet he felt the power of it as if
it spoke to him aloud this was the
founding stone of the tower this was the
central place and it was cold bitter
cold nothing could ever warm the little
room this was a very ancient thing an
old and terrible spirit was prisoned in
this block of stone
she says this is the pteranodon do you
wonder that we keep so precious a jewel
locked away
in our deepest hoard room he says tell
me of its powers
and then she says it was made before
segoy raised the islands of the world
from the open sea it was made when the
world itself was made and will endure to
the end of the world time is nothing to
it if you lay your hand upon it and ask
a question of it it will answer
according to the power that is in you
it has a voice if you know how to listen
it will speak of things that were and
are and will be it's hold of your coming
long before you came to this land will
you ask a question of it now
no it will answer you there's no
question i would ask it
finally she asked do you fear the stone
and he answers
yes
and
you know ged actually says something
quite smart here he says
i'm not going to talk with that spirit
that spirit is so sealed in a stone and
that stone is locked by a binding spell
and blinding spell and charm of lock and
ward and triple fortress walls in a
barren land
not because it is precious but because
it can work great evil
and she wants him to touch the stone she
tells him you'll be able to be master of
it
what he realizes however
here's here's the passage
he saw how indeed he had been drawn here
lured here how they used his fear to
lead him on and how they would once they
had him have kept him
they had saved him from the shadow
why
not because they loved him cared for him
they did not want him to be possessed by
the shadow until he had become a slave
of the stone once his will was captured
by the power of the stone they would let
the shadow into the walls for a gebbeth
was a better slave even than a man if he
had once touched the stone or spoken to
it he would have been utterly
lost
now as it turns out
uh
benderesque who is the lord of the
pteranodon wants this for her
ged he wants him to become the slave but
sarat also is playing a game as well she
wants to use it against
her lord but also to ensnare ged and so
what we see is all these people at cross
purposes with each other and this
ancient power
that would make him a slave once again
using ged's own power
what else can we say about this
issue the school of rock
which is very important
in the story occupies several chapters
sends ged out as a trained
mage
after he has had his schooling ged will
eventually in later books become himself
much more important to the school of
rock i won't say exactly how if you
haven't read it but what are the masters
doing the masters are teaching their
pupils who are going to become
at least sorcerers or wizards and
perhaps actual mages
teaching them
how to understand
power they teach them about the
equilibrium they teach them about
responsibility not all mages wind up
being good people as a result the
masters are not infallible
and what they do
doesn't always stick but they and some
of them can actually be corrupted
themselves as we'll find out in later
books
but they certainly make an attempt to
inculcate
a certain
sense of responsibility
for their their charges
and what they try to do is help them
understand some of the dangers some of
the temptations in having power some of
which ged himself succumbs to
one of these is ignorance again is told
listen you try to spell that you didn't
really know how to control you tried to
raise the dead and you ended up opening
up the door to so much more than just
the spirit that you were after that was
foolish that was a result of ignorance
don't be ignorant like that
again
ambition is another major thing
that
those who have magic must struggle with
and if they don't master it
it will master them and we see this
happen
throughout the books yet to come finally
the passions the emotions what is get
driven by
that leads him to doing this this
terrible thing that leads to the death
of the ark mage
at the time and the the need to elect a
new one
he gives into envy to anger to to all of
these negative passions
that lead him astray greed could be
another one and these lead people into
doing wrong which then has to be if it
can be at all
fixed in one way
or another so this is a very important
dynamic running through this book we can
say that part of what ged is being
schooled by not only at rock
but also through his encounters with
ogean
and also i would say in his final
engagements with his friend
vetch who he trained with at roke and
who will help him
in the end confront his shadow
part of what he's learning is that power
is much more complicated than it seems
it can be used for great good
but it can also be turned to
great evil as well and you often have to
make split-second decisions about which
way you're going to go
as gad himself does in the narrative
you